at what point did you then go in front
of the camera or decide that you want to
direct like you so you're working with
props you're working more behind the
scenes and then when do you get to be in
front of the camera so it was 95 and I
was working on the chamber which is a
film with John Grisham novel with James
Foley who directed it
it was Gene Hackman and Chris O'Donnell
in it and so we were shot in LA but then
we traveled to Jackson Mississippi who's
about a guy on death row and if I'm up
here he's like they're worried the worse
least successful - John Grisham novels
and films adaption of the novel and so
we were on I was on set and the I was on
I was assistant prop master and then a
friend of mine was the onset dresser and
we were always you know hustling to you
know do this job we were doing you know
working really hard and the director you
know sort of saw that we were you know
young and hungry and you know so he
wanted to sort of be friends with us
because we were like always joking
having fun and stuff and so he at one
point you know took the the the
walkie-talkie said it's not cool you
guys all get to talk on the walkies but
I don't so we gave him one of our
walkies and he said there on the walkie
changing channels talking to the
assistant director talking to the key
grip and everybody's like why is the
director on on the on the walkies you
know he's not supposed to be to let
leave him and to do this thing but it
just became this this this great
relationship and on set he was just you
know asked me one day is like so what is
it you wanted to do when you grow up I
was like well you know I like props you
know I think you know do a couple more
this is a prop master maybe I'll get to
be a prop master he's like nah like we
mean nah he's like now you're you're too
good like you don't care like I can tell
you don't care about the job but like
you're good but you know it's not what
you want to do there's like oh well he's
like don't tell me
but he said successful people know what
they want to do
and they write it out they set a time
when they want to do it by and they put
amount of money they're gonna have in
the bank and then they just do it and
then they tell everybody that's what
they're doing I was like okay so next
day I'm show up on set and he asked me
did you write it down I was like no now
I thought about it but it was such a
confront like you know it was like the
first day on set I was like watching
actors like oh this is awesome you know
like I get to see what they do is like
oh yeah I want to be an actor then I saw
the director giving directions on what
directing is cool too and then it's like
oh the gaffer lighting setting up the
shot there's like so many things that I
like to do but it's just like it's so
scary
to be an actor to say oh I'm gonna be an
actor now like I think I'll just stay as
a PA I'll just stay as a driver I'll
stay as a prop guy that's just safer and
it was good money and so it was like you
know I don't remember like on my second
movie an electrician was you know
literally the time I was not smoking but
like it hung out with smokers apparently
cuz he was smoking by the truck and he
was saying he's like yeah man you gotta
be careful cuz the money is so good you
don't want to leave so whatever it is
gonna do man you should do it cuz you're
gonna get sucked into this and go
paychecks good and then you do another
movie and then it's another movie and
it's like nah that's not gonna happen to
me so here I am on set and talking to
the director so the next day I wrote out
you know I want to be an actor writer
director producer I'm gonna start doing
it after this next movie excited the
movie lined up right after I'm gonna
have $10,000 in the bank and I'm gonna
do it on December 1st 1995 so I came in
the next day and I said so I wrote it
down I want to be an actor writer
director producer he's like okay it's
like actor worst job you have no control
over anything writer you get no credit
producer hardest job and you get no like
nobody cares what you do it's just
you're responsible for everything he's
like director that's the job
he's like hey man whatever you want to
do but do it because you now wrote it
down and so I did I literally had that I
had a movie right after his doing
this movie the volcano here in LA and so
I that first day that I started I knew I
was gonna finish on December first and I
told everybody I told the first ad at
one point and she ended up getting me
apart has this rookie cop and I got to
get my sag card I told the producers
within the pretty while we were prepping
and so when we were shooting when the
producers numerous would walk up to me
and say so what do you think should we
break for lunch or should we just do a
walking meal you know all those kind of
things would just sort of I would tell
people this is what I wanted to do
director I talked to him and asked him
why he'd picked this shot I mean I'm
doing my job it's not like I'm that guy
just like hanging out so people were
were open to talking about that and then
I finished that and I literally took off
six months and I started an acting class
I took a directing workshop at AFI I
started writing and did a workshop
through which used to be film and not
film independent it used to be something
else and now it's find and and then a
producing course through AFI as well and
so I remember I remember uh showing up
at a film independent events like three
months after that you have to have a
little tag on your thing and this is you
know what you're when you sign up like
what your profession is so I thought it
was like I'm well what am I here for I'm
like actor writer director producer so I
wrote that all down and I met this guy
he's a con man so what have you done and
I was like oh I thought this was just
like what you wanted to be when you grow
up like I didn't I didn't know and he
and I are still friends to this day like
we are still we still talk we're still
on Facebook you know connecting with
each other but he was just so like no
that's my works you got to be doing
something like why I mean I'm saying I
want to do this so how else will people
know if I they don't know what I want to
do so I mean it and that's a whole
nother story for me it's just sort of
like how hard it is to say you want to
do more than just one thing because you
know people really want to just go but
yeah but what do you really want to do
you know what is it we have to focus on
one thing and so it's
just listening this great TED talk about
how you can't be great at why you're not
gonna be great at one thing this woman
Helene something about multi like a
multi professional like you have
different different different areas of
your life like you're a hair stylist and
you also you know a violinist you know
somebody that does multiple things which
is what I think I am so got way off
track on Mike white on your question but
no no it's an interesting journey that
you you've taken us on so with that
director did that set in motion you
writing things down that challenge oh
yeah absolutely yeah absolutely so that
that really pushed me into realizing
that I had to you know we have some
accountability to what I wanted to do so
I end up getting a white board and you
know writing out my goals all the time
it's something I do I still do to this
day I'll write out I have a friend of
mine that sort of like an accountability
partner we email each other Monday
Wednesday and Friday we sort of these
are our goals for the 90 days actions
I'm taking towards each of these goals
here's what I'm doing this week and you
know just kind of ups mine my game
because it's so easy to get sort of
stuck by myself sitting in front of my
computer like how am I supposed to get
from A to Z and so and then it's also
great because there's like sort of
markers of like oh I'm getting there I'm
getting closer to you know the end of
the year it's not like you know I didn't
what I do this year it's like I did a
ton of stuff I used to the last couple
years before I just had a baby
four months 14 months ago so I did my
wife did but thank you Kevin and so but
it is my office is now his bedroom and
so but on at the time I had painted the
one wall in my in my office
chalkboard black and I started writing
down you know a person was just sort of
projects and things updates things I was
doing then I was getting frustrated and
my projects weren't going where I wanted
them to go so what I did was I shifted
that and I just like we were going on
vacation that's like I'm just end of the
era I was like I just had to clean this
whole wall if I'm just these projects
I'm just so
frustrated because I have like 25
projects and like I can't control any of
the stuff that's on this wall it's just
so frustrating so he went on vacation
and I came back and it was like a blank
wall and so I was like well what-what
can I not I don't want to put anything
on there that's just just to put it up
there you know cuz I was getting ready
to have a meeting for something one of
our projects and I was gonna put it up
there and I was like man instead I put
God's will which sort of like I'm the
universe whatever you whatever you want
I'm just gonna put it up there and if I
get something if something happens a
meaning if something moves forward then
I'll write it up there but I'm not gonna
sort of put my intention visit all the
things I want and so sort of don't know
why I thought of it don't know why I did
that but what ended up happening was
every time I got a meeting every time I
got an opportunity every time I met
somebody every time I had an audition at
booked something you know project was
moving forward wrote something whatever
those things were finished an outline
I'd write all those things on the board
and so at the end of six months I was
like oh wow this is like a lot of stuff
is happening and then by the end of that
first year it was so clear to me that I
you know I didn't know any of those
things we're gonna happen
so like the day before those things
happen I had no idea
now I had like intentions of like all
the things that I want and what I want
from my career in my life but the
specifics of you know how I was gonna
get them I had no idea so sort of like
this weird thing of like how do I get
from A to B I don't really know how it's
gonna happen I know that I want B and so
I take a ton of actions I do a ton of
stuff that's risky and then we'll see
what happens and out of that all these
things sort of polish over here shines
over here and so at the end of the year
I was looking like holy God like my life
is huge like I've had this something an
amazing year and it wasn't none of those
things were things that I could have
come up with like if I had said here are
the things I want to me want to be
directing a Capital One commercial I
want to be directing and Nissan Heisman
spots with you know these amazing NFL
football players like I couldn't
couldn't my aperture of what my
possibilities were it was like this
but when I just sort of opened up
I don't know what's exactly gonna happen
but I want to be directing I want to be
writing I'm gonna be producing I want to
be acting these are the things I want to
be doing want to be with these kind of
people this level of people and this
thing happens so I did that for two
years then we had the baby and so it's
just like I had to like clean it up but
it was such a huge thing for me and
actually miss it I've missed it this
year and I was thinking about it
actually this morning gonna make nothing
there right we have a whiteboard that's
behind our know my wife and I share an
office and it's behind one of our
sliding doors but we haven't put
anything on it we didn't land one though
let's see what we'll do what kind of
maybe we'll do something different this
year and it's you know it's just like oh
he's alive we have to keep him alive
that's what it started like our goal
right now is that you know and so but
I'm singing ah there's so many things
happening just from yesterday that I
would love to build like oh I didn't
know that was gonna happen oh this is
really cool isn't happening so I wrote
on my notebook and it's like I might do
that you know later on today what if he
wants to become a screenwriter and I
don't produce which well you know
whatever he wants to do I mean we
basically we were talking about that
because somebody was talking one of our
families like so do you guys have a
college fund set up forum and were like
wow yeah but you know he doesn't want to
go to college he doesn't have to go to
college neither of us went to college
you know and you know at the same time
we're saying to school like just you
know we had a perspective of school we
have one now and it's like you know we
want him to have as much opportunity as
possible and as much knowledge as
possible we don't want us to force him
we already tried to force him to like
eat what we wanted to eat do what we
wanted to do that's not working so I
don't think it's gonna be successful
when he's and you know I'm graduating
from high school so we just really want
to try to if he wants to be a
screenwriter if he wants to act if he
wants to you know if he's you know wants
to be a hairstylist he seems to want to
help her do her makeups and maybe he'll
be a makeup artist you know
so yeah whatever he wants so well I know
we were talking earlier and and about
you know safety and and there's no real
safe route especially post-recession
I think a lot of what maybe our parents
generation thought was safe the nor
was one thing and there was always that
you know my grandparents generation get
it you know job with a pension and since
a lot of that safety is not there
anymore I think it's it's like kind of
like just she said like whoever's will
yeah it's you know yeah I think so too I
think that it I think it was more time
to change so much it used to be I mean
it just that was how it used to be it
used to be a very simplified way of
looking at things and now I mean I had
so many friends that parents had lost
everything and you know the market
crashed they had all this money in their
house then they went underwater and they
had nothing you know and so it was just
all their savings was like oh well we
have it in equity in her house and then
when that went away it was like there's
nothing and so there is no safe there's
no like I'm just gonna started a bank
teller and make it to bank manager and
Bank is probably the wrong thing cuz of
course there you know banks always win
the big banks seem to never get arrested
or anything so they can you saw the big
guys nothing happens they just rename
them babies rename or get exactly just
buy another bank another
yeah sure change laws yeah exactly
you